hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be answering
your property
investment questions so let's do this
i've made millions of amounts in
property
and every single sunday i answer your
property investment questions so please
do me
a massive favor and smash the like
button
and also subscribe turn the notification
bell on
and comment your questions below if
there's no questions i can't keep making
videos
so anything you've got around property
tax hmos police option agreements
mortgages
comment them below and i'll answer your
questions next week but right now
we have a question that's just come in
from ian brooks
he says hi samuel i'm thinking of buying
a house for a hmo
how do you know or find out if a hmo
management company
is a good one so ian firstly they've got
to be a hmm management company
because and it's good that you said that
lots of
amateur landlords when they get into
hmos they just get
regular lane agents to rent out their
rooms no
good it's gonna kill your hmo business
how do you know if they're good
um so ring up some hmo specialists just
talk to them
maybe pretend to be a prospective tenant
and say hey i'm looking to rent a room
and see how they are do they answer the
phone are they professional
you know do they check to make sure that
you're the right caliber of tenant
um i think that's probably the best
thing to do also get some
recommendations
uh from other investors in the area good
luck with your hmo i hope that helps
let's see what we got next we've got
cameron mr cameron johnson he says i
live in newcastle
and there's a huge student let's and hmo
being built in the city center
there are now so many empty hmos in my
area
five minutes away does this mean that
hmos in newcastle
are dead uh no hmos in newcastle are not
dead
i don't know newcastle very well but i
know they're not dead because
look you've said that there's a student
let's be built in the city center
maybe your hmos are professional let's
i mean guaranteed if i go on spare room
dot co dot uk
right now guaranteed they'll be i mean
how big
is the hma you're looking again are you
looking at getting like a five-bed
six-bed hmo
guaranteed there's five or six people
new today
sunday right now there'll be five or six
people on spare room
that have advertised themselves looking
for rooms to rent in nuke
in newcastle today so the the demand is
there
the supply is also there so what you
need to do is you need to make sure
that your supply is good competitive not
just in price
but also that you can get some nice
high-end good properties guaranteed in
newcastle newcastle's cheap anyway so
the return on investment's really high
it's not dead absolutely not man maybe
i'll uh
cameron maybe i'll just come to
newcastle do a financial freedom
challenge just to prove you wrong but
100 not dead
all right next colin says great videos
when you remortgage a property do you
use a broker or is there a company or
direct remortgage way to get a better
deal
yeah i use a broker every time
independent mortgage broker that will
check the whole market
give me the best rates the best deal
always the best way to do it
zach collins thank you for answering my
previous question i've now purchased my
first investment property
boom that's what happens you ask
questions i
answer them then you go buy investment
properties and we get wealthy
good job congrats my question now is
when mortgaging
a property to rent out do you recommend
interest only mortgage and make more
income or
clear off the mortgage to benefit in the
long run i always
always recommend interest only mortgage
and
not only do i recommend getting a
mortgage but i recommend paying as
little as possible and not paying down
the mortgage
if you get a repayment mortgage it's
going to wipe out a lot of your cash
flow and you're going to be forced to
have to put down that each and every
month
if you have an interest only mortgage
hey if you feel like paying down the
mortgage you can
but you're not forced to on a repayment
mortgage so interest only is the best of
both
but personally i wouldn't save up to pay
mortgage off i'd use all that cash flow
to store up to invest in more properties
and invest in better bigger properties
so interest only all the way that's my
opinion
okay uh ali alimo i have a three-bedroom
property and now i'm thinking about
making it into a hmo how do i do that
do i need to speak to the council or
something
a lot of html questions today i'm loving
it so
if you want to turn into a hmo and it's
a three bed
it depends how many rooms generally
speaking this is a rule of thumb if
there's
four people in the house or less so if
you're
if you've got three rooms maybe you turn
one of the sitting rooms into another
bedroom
you've got four rooms you will not need
planning permission
you will not need any licensing so
you're not gonna need to
do anything legally sure you need to
make sure the house is safe and nice
you know put fire doors make sure it's
safe and it's it's appropriate
for four people the room sizes are 70
square feet but you won't need to go to
the council to seek any kind of approval
um or get any licenses
generally speaking now there are some
exceptions um if it's an area that has
selective licensing
um you might need to get a license but
generally you don't and also if it's in
an article
four area you might need well you will
need planning permission
so there are some exceptions so the that
my advice to you ali is
if you're not sure it doesn't harm
picking up the phone and speaking to the
council or just google it
just google you know hmo rules in and
put your area and you'll be able to work
out what you need do you need a license
do you need uh planning permission but i
hope that gives you a bit of a guidance
and rule of thumb thanks for your
question okay that
gman says when you buy a buy to let
under limited company
does the 25 deposit qualify as a
business expense
i wish it did i really wish it did so no
it no
generally it will it will never class as
business expense now
listen there are things you can do
there's always clever things you can do
with different types of properties like
if you're buying commercial property
out of your pension you can do that and
there's there's always clever things and
tax you can do but generally speaking
let's be really clear
because people get really confused out
of this they think if they've got a
business
and that business makes a hundred grand
and then they invest that in property
they don't need to pay tax on 100 grand
because they think well i made the
hundred grand but
i've invested it but yeah but you've
made a hundred grand
whenever you make money you need to pay
tax on it and no buying property is not
tax deductible
um so i'm really sorry to break that to
you but you're gonna have to pay taxes
now as i say there's always i mean um
richard
sorry robert kiyosaki says rich people
don't pay taxes and this is something
i'm learning
you know i never used to worry about
taxes until i started having to pay
millions of pounds in taxes
and i'm like geez maybe i should stop
thinking about taxes sometimes people
worry about taxes too soon
don't worry about saving money when you
start out worry about making money
um but as you as you start to make a lot
of money there are things you can do but
no
that is not tax deductible to put down
money to buy a house hope that answers
your question
thanks so much and guys if you
appreciate my channel if you like my
videos
if this is helpful if you're still
watching i know you all are i know you
are
of course because if you heard me say
that you are so do me a massive favor
okay smash the like button
also comment your questions as well
because i got i got to have
some good questions for next week so
comment your questions and of course
subscribe and turn the little bell on
because if you don't do that
maybe i'll answer your question next
week i'll give you the most amazing
answer
that could be your breakthrough to
financial freedom but you miss
it because you're not subscribed so
subscribe turn the notification bell on
alright
miles yeoman says hi stephen
great informative video i'm 19 years old
three-year apprentice electrician
i'm looking at my first property brr the
property is under value and i believe i
can add value to the property
the issue is i'm unlikely to secure a
buy to let mortgage i have the deposit
and refurb cash ready
the mortgage is my issue with my age any
advice it would be greatly appreciated
miles you just you just need um like a
mortgage host or something
uh tenants in common it's called speak
to speak to a broker about it
but if you put somebody on the property
even if they only have one percent
and then you use them as a guarantor to
get the finance and then
in a few years time once your finances
better you can refinance kick them off
this is a very very common thing that
happens all the time
obviously i'm not a tax or mortgage
advisor i can't give tax advice
but there are definitely ways around it
and uh speak to a broker and get that
sorted
good job all right matthew de la hunty
i'm just about to complete my first
freehold
flat congratulations love to see people
doing deals
my intention was to put it on
booking.com it's in north bristol i
would like to know if booking.com is
still viable strategy or
should i put it onto a long-term tenant
so if you've got a freehold flat firstly
you've got you've got no head lease
issues
as long as you've not got a mortgage
restricting you from doing it um it
might be smart
uh bristol the hotels in bristol are
pretty buzzing right now as far as i'm
concerned i mean i don't know bristol
super well i would say firstly
maybe even walk in walk into some hotels
in north bristol
and say to the receptionist have you got
any rooms tonight and if they say no you
can say okay
are you booked up a lot like what's
happening and find out what the area is
like for hotels because
if you're going to put your property on
booking.com you're competing with the
hotels
so you want to see in the area what the
hotels are doing look at what the
competition are doing
look at how busy they are go on airbnb
and see what's happening find some like
for like freehold apartments
and look at the calendars it's all free
information you can find you just need
to know where to look
um but hey why not give it a go
stick it on booking.com see what happens
and if it doesn't work
then change it over maybe that's your
answer but
personally if you stick a tenant in
there on a two-year lease uh you'll
probably be disappointed because
you're gonna get two three even four
times the amount of profit potentially
by having it as a serviced accommodation
on booking.com
so definitely pursue that good luck
km how long does it take to be able to
refinance your money is it six months
or can you do it as soon as you have
added value so
some lenders will let you refinance
within six months like um
i mean listen they're always changing
last time i checked
kent reliance would let you refinance
immediately before the six months so you
buy a house
you add value you can refinance and pull
your money out straight away precise
mortgages same story
i don't know if they're still doing that
but there are there are lenders that
will let you
but generally speaking if you are
prepared to wait six months you're going
to open yourself up to a lot more
lenders and you're gonna have a much
better rate
you're gonna be able to get a better
deal but there are lenders that will let
you refinance before six months yes
vinay recently finished your bilo rent
high book
thank you so much it's a great book it's
a really good book it provides good info
but you didn't mention what roi would
you recommend and what should be the
least roi that would work
so generally speaking vinay i look for a
20 return
on investments of course if you're not
putting in your own money and you're
using some of the other strategies that
we talk about in the book
like lease option agreements and you
know no money down deals raising finance
you're going to get an infinite return
on investment but 20
of your own money is the minimum that
you should really be looking for
in my book burning desire
good to have you back thank you for
always commenting you're amazing
do you think house prices will still go
down soon
like when the stamp duty relief is over
also how do you find houses that you can
add significant value to
so house price is short listen firstly
every area has got its own economy going
on i've said this before i've talked
about
um london going down liverpool going up
you know every different area has got
its own economy
so to answer your question do i think
house prices will go down when the stamp
duty relief is over i think yes
i mean just like i predicted i mean
april we had a dip
properties weren't selling it was crazy
people were selling their houses really
cheap
that lasted a few months house prices
went down consecutively four months in
the row
just a little bit but it was tough tough
market and then
sort of like uh july august time when
all the announcements started happening
planning permission was made easier
bounce back loans stamp duty holidays as
more and more things started happening
house prices suddenly started going up
now we're in a mini boom
and my prediction is that in 2021
there's going to be a housing crash
i've said this i mean everything i've
always predicted for the whole
last five years i've been predicting
stuff i did a prediction video about six
eight months ago
and um everything's looking pretty much
as i said of course i've not got a
crystal ball
but i look at patterns i study trends
and i like to give my thoughts so
i think yeah i do think there's going to
be a crash i think that it will happen
in 2021
but not in every area because in some
areas they've already crashed so low
they can't go down anymore
like liverpool for instance that's not
going to crash it's not going to crash
2021
but i think there will be a lot of areas
that do all right
olly gedney i want to do a buy select i
would put down 25
deposit and borrow the rest from friends
and family do i they
need to pay any gift tax or anything
like that not sure if there's any tax
implications when borrowing money thanks
for your time
so i don't think you need to borrow
money from friends and family if
you've got 25 deposit just borrow it
from the bank it's gonna be much cheaper
i don't know why you'd borrow it from
friends and family but if you do borrow
from friends and family
any any money that you pay them they're
gonna have to pay tax on any income they
make
generally speaking maybe get a tax
advisor on that but i wouldn't be
getting
uh family friends just get a mortgage
interest rates right now are
absolutely bottomed out low you can
borrow money from
the bank for next to nothing like two
three percent a year
interest and then you can invest it in
properties that give you 20 30
return on investment they're as low as
they've been for a very very long time
and you can fix them for a very long
time too so just just go to
a bank or go to a broker and get a loan
from a bank get a mortgage from a bank
lender
um don't be borrowing for family and
friends it just doesn't make sense
because they're not gonna they're not
gonna wanna lend you money at two three
percent
unless they're financially [ __ ] okay
next ash davis
hi samuel love the video i have a large
lump sum of money can't decide whether
to buy one large hmo outright or maybe a
few houses
also i live in london should i sell my
flat here and invest in cheaper area so
all the properties are in the same area
um ash i would recommend you get some
training
you know you you've got some money
you've got a flat you're looking at
selling it
i mean i would get some training i would
i would invest at least 10
of your money into yourself invest in
yourself first and then property second
um that'd be my first advice secondly
i'd be looking at doing brr strategy
recycling your cash so you're talking
about should i buy one
outright no don't don't buy one hmo
outright
uh unless you're then gonna refinance
and pull your money out you want your
money to go as far as it can
as far as it can um all right jamie
mcdonald i'll do this last one and then
we'll wrap up
in an article four area does it make
sense to buy an existing hmo
there or not will it make more sense to
try and get permission on a new hmo if
this is possible
if you're in an article 4 area jamie the
problem is if you try
and get planning permission you're
probably going to struggle now that
might be your strategy maybe you're in
with the council and you've got some
tricks and stuff but generally speaking
getting planning permission
on to buy a house and turn it into a hmo
in an article 4 area
is going to be bad news buying a hmo
that's already got planning permission
it's going to be expensive it's going to
be a premium because
article 4's in said there's no more it's
like limited edition cars
you know limited edition hmos hmos are
going to get harder and harder
and they're going to be a thing where
people go those were the does in like
five six years time
so my advice would be find an area
that's not article four
buy their cheap turn it into a hmo wait
for article four to come in
and then you will own the premium and
you will have the grandfather rights
get into hmos and get in there fast
because honestly there's the time right
now
is very very good so guys thank you for
watching this i hope you found it
helpful
comment your questions below i'm going
to be doing more videos if you want to
just watch more q a sunday videos you
can check them out i do it every week
check them out up right here
if you want to see stories of people
that i've helped become financially free
check them out right here and please
don't forget do me a massive favor and
subscribe just take
five seconds to subscribe you can do
that right here thank you so much i'll
see you next time peace out